[موسيقى]
انا عارف مجموعتنا في كاس العالم
في البطوله المجموعه صعبه
او تعادل اللي نبغى منكم تلعبون لعبكم
المريح اللي يؤدي وان شاء الله القادم
افضل انا ما ابغى اي احد يكون تحت ضغط
نفسي يمكن يؤثر حتى على همم ادائكم
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه في
تغطيه خاصه ليوم فارق في تاريخ الكره
السعوديه بعد المفاجاه الاكبر في تاريخ
كاس العالم قبل الوصول الى ليله الحسن بعد
اقل من ست ساعات فاب الى استاد الوسيل في
قطر تتجه انظار السعوديين والعالم العربي
حيث المباراه الحاسمه للمنتخب السعودي
امام المكسيك بعد ان حقق صقور الاخضر احدى
اكبر المفاجات في تاريخ كاس العالم
بالتغلب على الارجنتين في اولى مبارياتهم
في المونديال في مستوى لفت انظار العالم
اجمع الى المنتخب السعودي الذي اصبح حديث
الساعه حتى رغم في ثاني مبارياته امام
بولندا الا انا طموح السعوديين يدفعهم
للبحث عن فرصه التاهل الى الدور الثاني
عبر بوابه المكسيك هذه الليله لاعاده
الانجاز السعودي الاول في البطوله عام 494
معكم بعض ردود فعلي الجماهير حول هذه
المباراه المصيريه من شوارع السعوديه
والعالم العربي
باذن الله المباراه القادمه اللي هي
الليله ان شاء الله بتكون واحد صفر
للسعوديه باذن الله تعالى
وبسبب الروح اللي عندهم
همم اتوقع اثنين واحد بس السعوديه
بالاداء العظيم جدا جدا انا ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله متوقع اثنين واحد للمنتخب
السعودي والله انا متوقع ان شاء الله
المنتخب اليوم 2-0 ان شاء الله محمد
متكلمه ان شاء الله يا رب ان شاء الله
متفاعلين
وفخوريين بقياده ومنتخب همم اليوم الكل
عربي وكل سعودي وان شاء الله اتمنى الفوز
للمنتخب السعودي واحد صفر
اليوم المباراه ان شاء الله اثنين صفر بس
الى حساسلها سالم الدوسري
[موسيقى]
في هذه التغطيه شبكه مراسله العربيه من
الدوحه منفذ العربيه ليث بزاري ومن مسقط
موفد العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي وبانتظار
ايضا الزميل عبد المحسن الحربي نعم عبد
المحسن معنا ايضا من الدوحه مرحبا بكم معي
جميعا ابدا معك ليث ترقب كبير لهذه
المباراه
السعوديه والمكسيك كيف هي الاجواء من حولك
طلال مداح الجميع يتحضر هنا في البيت
السعودي الشباب وصلوا للتو الى هذا المكان
والفرحه والتسجيع والفوز ان شاء الله في
عيونها اذا اخذنا الكاميرا سوف نشاهد
الشباب السعودي الذين يصلون الى هذه
المنطقه ونحن طبعا في وسط الدوحه على شاطئ
اللوح على شاطئ همم اللؤلؤه ليس بعيد عن
اللؤلؤه ولكن في البيت السعودي وهنا ان
نشاهد الكثير المتحمسون وشاهدنا قبل قليل
في السماء الطائرات الطائران السوع
السعودي السعوديه همم تنقل ركاب ومشجعين
ومحبين منتخب ياتون من المناطق مختلفه من
وين جايين جايين من الدمام والله
من بعيد
يعني قريب من اللاعبين حتى نشوفهم يعني
هذول الشباب
متى وصلت
الليل كم النتيجه برايك بفوز المنتخب
عم هذه الاجواء يعني كثير اذا اخذنا
الكاميرا من المناطق الاخرى نشاهد قال
يعني الموسيقى الحماس ال ال الوصول الى
هذه المنطقه
والاقتراب والاقتذار الانتظار
هيك بايجابيه
للمشاهده المباراه وطبعا هنا قدام هنا
شاشه همم شاشه العرض التي ستعرض عليها ال-
ال- المباراه هنا في هذه المنطقه من
الدوحه والكثير يعني شاهدت الكثير من
الشباب الذين قصدوا البيت السعودي يبحثون
عن تذاكر سمع انه يوجد في متجر همم البيت
السعودي تذاكر وكان يعني همم اللي صدمنا
انه كميه الشباب الذين وصلوا كان في تذاكر
المنطقه
كثير كان في سماعات صوت مكبرات صوت تقول
رجاءا اذا انتم هنا في في السعودي لا يوجد
تذاكر ويمكنكم البقاء هنا لمشاهده
المباراه على هذه الشاشه الطقمه التي
نشاهد خلفي يعني هذه الاجواء لحد هذه
اللحظه وبعد بكير على المباراه بتوقع بعد
لسه ما عاد عندنا خمس ساعات للمباراه
والوصول الحسود السعوديه وصلت
ايضا تنتقل لمنطقه اخرى في البيت السعودي
وانتقل ايضا بالصوره الى زميلنا عبد
الرحمن
العصيمي من مسقط عبد الرحمن يبدو انك انت
ايضا في منطقه خاصه بالمشجعين في همم عمان
كيف تابعوا البطوله المنتخب السعودي احنا
نعرف الشعب العماني الشعب هذا شعب ذواق في
متابعه كره القدم ايش توقعاتهم لمباراه
اليوم يا عبد الرحمن
هو فعلا الشعب العماني الشعب هادئ الا في
كره القدم صراحه قبل يوم السبت مباراه
السعوديه وبولندا كان موجودين في هذا
المكان مهرجان مشجعين كره القدم هذا
المكان المخصص لمتابعه مباريات كاس العالم
كان هناك اكثر من 4000 عماني وعماني كلهم
يشجعون المنتخب السعودي ويقفون وراء
الصقور الخضر دعما لهم في مباريات لعزميلي
يريد ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات هذا المكان
الذي خصصته همم وزاره السياحه وايه التراث
والسياحه للمباريات وايضا
لتقديم الفعاليات للمشجعين كما نشاهد هناك
المطاعم والمقاهي كلها هذه المطاعم
والمقاهي تعود الى شباب عمانيين همم لدعم
المشاريع الصغيره والمتوسطه ايضا هناك
تقريبا ثلاث شاشات همم متوزعه على هذه
المناطق لتقديم المباريات وايضا عرضها
للمشجعين هذا المكان مفتوح الجميع
للاستمتاع بالمباريات وتقديمها اولا
والصناخذ نايف سريعا راي بعض الشباب
العمانيين مساء الخير يا شباب كيف حالكم
ها كيف السعوديه اليوم توقعاتكم فوز
السعوديه اليوم ان شاء الله نتمنى لهم
التوفيق وان شاء الله يفوزوا اثنين واحد
باذن الله
ما عليه كلام ولكن المنتخب السعودي يعني
عطونا نظره صراحه همم خلتنا نروح
بالتوقعات الى ابعد الحدود ان شاء الله
ونتمنى لهم الفوز باذن الله اعطيني
النتيجه كم هتكون اليوم ان شاء الله
السلام عليكم النتيجه اليوم واحد صفر
صالح اليوم ان شاء الله ومتاكد انه اليوم
بيفوز السعوديه واحنا كلنا مع الاخضر
اليوم
حرام يعني السعوديه يطلع من على الاقل
يوصل لدور 16 واليوم ان شاء الله
المنتخب اثناء كاس العالم المنتخب السعودي
ان شاء الله باذن الله يعني نايف الجميع
متفائل كمان شاهد الجميع متحمس لمباراه
السعوديه
والمكسيك الليله طبعا تبقى ساعات قليله
ههه توقع ساعات قليله على المباراه
يعني الجميع متحمس وان شاء الله يا رب
اليوم المنتخب السعودي همم يعني يقدم
مباراه رائعه و يرفع راسنا ان شاء الله
باذن الله وهم متحمسين
واحنا متحمسين ويعني في في توتر بعضها شيء
خليني اروح لعبد المحسن ايضا وهو في منطقه
همم يعني مكتظه بالجماهير ربما المشجع
لكاس العالم ويشوف جماهير مكسيكيه عبد
الرحمن ما اعرف اذا كانت هذه منطقه مخصصه
للمكسيكيين ولا شيء عبد المحسن
بالحقيقه نايف نتواجد هنا في سوق نايف حيث
في سوق واقف حيث يتواجد العديد من
المشجعين قبل قليل المره عدد من المشجعين
المكسيكان في هذه المنطقه فبالتالي بدا
الجمهور السعودي
بترديد الاهازيج ممازحه عن هذا الجمهور
بين المباريات او المباراه الحاسبه قبل
خمسه ساعات من هنا حيث يتواجد عدد كبير
جدا من الجمهور السعودي
للاستمتاع ربما ببعض الوقت وبعضهم ايضا
نزل يبحث عن التذاكر عدد ضخم كبير جدا
نايف تواجد في الدوحه اليوم لحضور مباراه
المنتخب السعودي ضد المكسيكي من السعوديه
مليئه بالسعوديين الكثير منهم لديه تذاكر
وايضا الكثير الاخر ليس لديهم تذاكر
المباراه اليوم نتحدث منين طيب
حابب تشوف المباراه اليوم والله اذا ما
حصلت تذاكر اكيد بالساحات
متفائل اليوم في المباراه نعم متفائلين
وباذن الله واحد صفر تقول لمنتخب السعودي
هيرنا المدرب المنتخب قال لا احضره بكتابه
ضربنا المشاوي
شكرا جزيلا ننتقل الى واحد من
الابطال هنا من وين جيت
طيب من اي مدينه
تازر المنتخب السعودي كلمني عن توقعاتك
2 2
[موسيقى]
ايضا اذا هنالك وقت الكثير من الجمهور
السعودي
المنتخب اليوم طيب كلمنا عن توقعاتك اليوم
امنياتك للمباراه وين بتشوفها قبل المنتخب
ان شاء الله واثق فيهم بيفوزون اهم شيء
يكون اللعب هذه ومركزين ان شاء الله بحضر
في الملعب
بشكل مباشر والله يوفقنا جميعا والله ينصر
المنتخب شكرا
مساند المنتخب في اي وقت اي مكان ان شاء
الله باذن الله شكرا بالتوفيق اذا نايف
كما تشاهد عدد كبير من الجمهور الحقيقه
هناك همم عدد ايضا يريد ان يشارك طيب بشكل
سريع توقعاتكم مباراه همم ان شاء الله راح
نفوز ان شاء الله باذن الله اثنين واحد
كلنا يعني متحمسين المباراه وعندنا مره فل
فان شاء الله ان شاء الله انها تنتهي
السعوديه باذن الله باروح نفرح باذن الله
كما يقول الجمهور السعودي
[موسيقى]
ههه
نعم لايف اهم ضيف عمرا شفته بالمنطقه هون
هو شاب اسمه سعود وصل قال لي انا ممكن
اطلع على الكاميرا انا بشجع الفريق انا
المنتخب السعودي اعشقه قلت طيب شو كيف
بتشجع المنتخب حكالي شوف
اوه
المنتخب عند هذا الطفل سعود رسم على ايده
العلم السعودي وفخور حكى لي شغله غريبه
قال لي انا بكره ان شاء الله راح ارجع مع
المنتخب سعود
اني اجازه
المدارس رح تنتهي ولا المنتخب ان شاء الله
ما يرجع لبعد البطوله
بالضبط بالضبط
الشماليه المنطقه الوسطى المنطقه الغربيه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه هون يقدم الطعام
السعوديون يوجد من جنسيات الاخرى هنا في
طاوله ما بعرف من وين جايين بالضبط ادرس
اللغه العربيه
امامين انجازات كمان مره بالعربي ههه
[ضحك]
ادرس العربيه
البطوله ليش يدعم المنتخب السعودي اليوم
اول برزنتر نايف سبورتاج
[موسيقى]
مختلفه يمكن الواحد ان يمارسها يتفرج على
غروب الشمس يتفرج على ما يحدث همم في هذه
المنطقه جميله اشكرك يا ليث ابقى معي طبعا
ساعود اليك همم والى الزملاء ايضا شبكه
مراسله العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
مسقط وعبد المحسن ايضا من الدوحه شكرا لكم
سعود لكم مره اخرى بعد ان نتوقف لفاصل همم
قصير او قبله انه نتابع مرصدته الكاميرا
العربيه مشاهدينا من حاله التفاؤل التي
تعيشها الجماهير العربيه قبيله مواجهه
المنتخب السعودي بنظيره المكسيكي ضمن
منافسات المجموعه الثالثه للصعود لدور ال
16 مشاهده
تكسب وتفرحنا وناسعد ان شاء الله النتيجه
ان شاء الله هتبقى اثنين واحد باذن الله
السعوديه فريق قوي جدا همم وانا اصلا من
المحبين السعوديه فان شاء الله ان هي تسعد
النهارده
واا توقعاتي ان هي تجيب 2/0 ان شاء الله
السعوديه يعني تعملها بقى عشان المره اللي
فاتت لعبت ماتش كبير قوي بس يعني ما كانش
في توفيق لها فان شاء الله باذن الله
النهارده يعني اا 2-0 باذن الله كنت وقعت
ان شاء الله السعوديه 2-0 باذن الله تعالى
ان شاء الله السعوديه الموق الاخضر ما
بيتوقف وان شاء الله تكون رايته خفاقه
والسعوديه قادره على الفوز
اذا انمسك في المباراه ان شاء الله قدها
اثنين واحد اثنين واحد ان شاء الله كلنا
ثقه
وان شاء الله نتمنى لهم الفوز وباذن الله
بيتاهل للدور 16 وباذن الله يتاهل
النهائيات ان شاء الله
ويجيبوا الفخر ما بس للسعوديه للعرب كامل
ان شاء الله
تصل قصير نواصل بعده هذه التغطيه الخاصه
للمنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه من نشره الرابعه والتي نتناول فيها
الحدث
الاستثنائيه هذه الليله مباراه المنتخب
السعودي امام نظيره المكسيكي المباراه
التي ستحسم احدى بطاقات التاهل من هذه
المجموعه مجموعه المنتخب السعودي التي تضم
ايضا الارجنتين و بولندا هذه الليله
مباراه الحزم
في مونديال قطر الان تحول الى شبكه مراسل
العربيه الموجوده ايضا في قطر وكذلك ايضا
في مسقط ارحل في مره اخرى من مسقط عفوا من
مسقط عبد الرحمن العصيمي مفيد العربيه من
الدوحه ايضا عبد المحسن الحربي في سوق
واقف بذلك سيعود الينا زميل عبد الحسين
الحربي همم عبد الرحمن كنت في منطقه قبل
قليل تتحدث مع بعض المشجعين العمانيين همم
الان همم
هذه المنطقه كذلك ياسر عبد الرحمن عن
اجواء كاس ال- العالم الجماهير الموجوده
في عمان في هذه البطوله لمنتخبات التي
تتابعها تشجعها همم من مارسته انت حيث
تنقلت في عدد من المناطق في عمان
نعم النايف في المباريات المنتخبات
العربيه تلاقي زخم كبير هنا في مسقط قبل
ايام عندما همم فاز المنتخب المغربي على
نظيره البلجيكي كان هناك احتفالات كبيره
من الرجال المغربيه همم في مسقط ايضا بعد
قليل مباراه تونس
فرنسا ايضا شاهدت اكثر من همم نعم اكثر من
همم شخص من الجاليه التونسيه ايضا موجودين
هنا في مسقط يشجعون المنتخب بعض الاعلام
التونسيه ايضا الجمهور العماني اساسا
يؤازر المنتخبات العربيه بشكل همم كبير
يعني مباريات السعوديه وايضا مباريات
منتخب قطر الماضيه كان الجمهور العماني
حاضر بقوه سنكم جارتنا في همم مهرجان
مشجعين كره القدم والان عندنا اثنين من
الشباب
همم اليوم شو رايك في المباراه كيف شايفها
كيف شايف حظوظ المنتخب السعودي والله
توقعاتي من السعوديه يتاهلوا يروحوا في
ااا المكسيك يتهرب انا الصراحه المستوى
اللي قدموه في البطوله للحين مستوى جبار
صراحه ووو اتوقع ان يسووها مين اللاعب
اللي ممكن تراهن عليه بالمنتخب السعودي
ممكن يعمل فرق في المباراه اليوم
كانه صراحه همم نجم بالنسبه لي امانه لها
عليه
كره القدم
الحب الكره وفي شغب كبير اتجاه الكره
منتخبنا ما وصل للضيعه بس نشجع كل المنتخب
العربي موجود في البطوله هذه يعطيك
العافيه
الاسئله مع احد من الشباب العماني اسمه
الكريم عبد الله كيف شايف اليوم مباراه
المنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
اللعب ان شاء الله بكل قوتهم بيلاعبوا ان
شاء الله نشوف مباراه اليوم هنا في مهرجان
مشجعين باذن الله ان شاء الله اتمنى بقيه
تشوف المباراه على الارض هذا الارض
نتمنى ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا نايف ايضا
وصل جوله سريعه شفته اليوم احد من
الشباب من الجاليه المصريه مساء الخير همم
ما شاء الله قعدت تشوف بعد فيديوهات
قطر الناس بتعمل تغطيه لاخواتنا السعوديين
هم اليومين دول يعني هم فخر العرب شرفونا
جدا جدا الماتش اللي فات مش عايز اقول لك
تتفرج على الناس هنا وهي بتتفرج على
الماتش عامله ازاي الناس كلها ازاي بقى
مكانها وسايبه شغلها وقاعدين اكنهم
سعوديين يعني كل الناس اللي كانت موجوده
هنا في عمان وهما بيتفرجوا على الماتش ما
فيش واحد غير لما كان واقف على رجليه ما
فيش واحد غير لما تحس ان هو كان قاعد
بيلعب معهم في الملعب
وانا بادعيها كنت باتمناها بس اخواتنا
بردك موجودين هناك دلوقت واحنا بعيد عن
الضحى طبعا احنا بنتشرب باهل السعوديه
وبنتمنى لهم الفلوس
العربيه مع بعضنا فبنتمنى ان فيهم مشرفنا
توقعاتك المباراه اليوم كيف شايفها يا رب
يا رب يا رب ربنا يجبر بخاطرهم وينصرهم
همم اهل السعوديه كلهم نلاقيهم في الشارع
النهارده
بيرقصوا وبيفرحوا هما في السعوديه واحنا
هنا سلطنه عمان بنهيص لهم وانا هاهيص معك
ان شاء الله الليله لما يفوز المنتخب
السعودي
وبنتمنى لكم ان الكاس بتاع قطر ده يبقى
خارج من عند الامير تمام الى محمد بن
سلمان صح كده باذن الله هو ما يخرجش بره
السعوديه بامرك يا رب ربنا يكرمكم ويوفقكم
النهارده كل خير
وتفاؤل كبير وحماس من قبل همم
ولكن هذه المره يبدو ان عندك شيء مختلف
ومرتبط مؤمن ههه تفضل
نعم عبد الرحمن دائما بتحفنا بالاكل مش بس
انا على كل حال
عندنا اكل اجانا من المملكه طبعا تاكيا
طبعا مطعم تكه بالرياض وصل هون هذا ايه
كبيره
وعنبه بليله نشوف للمشجعين السعوديين
عندنا هريس كمان راح تجوعه معنا يا
مشاهدين بعتذر بس لانه هيك الوضع
عريكه موجود معنا كمان عريكه شو هذا موجود
هون للمشجعين لمشجعين منتخب السعودي وصلوا
الحلو بالموضوع هذا ايش
كرات المرسى
تعرف يعني ما بتحمل انا لازم اذوق هذا
الشيء
خلينا نهرب بلاش السعرات تعال تعال
طيب هون اذا بتشوف عجبني بالموضوع اسماء
المناطق يعني كل كوخ يقدم اكل المنطقه
الوسطى بتلاقي اكل من السعوديه
للمنطقه الشماليه من المناطق الجنوب هذا
حلو يعني انه الواحد ممكن يكون يشاهد
المباراه وياكل ويتمتع ويشوف اصدقاء
ويتعرف على ناس كمان فقط
طولنا شويه على نواف وسامحنا يا نواف لكن
يعني انت شايف اجواء ال- ال- المونديال
المشجعين ايضا انت في منطقه همم ايضا اخرى
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضيه التي تنتظر
نتيجه ايجابيه واعلان تاهل المنتخب
السعودي اليوم الى الدور الثاني في بطوله
كاس العالم في قطر انت يبدو في المطار
نواف كيف
منذ الصباح ومنذ ايضا حتى الايام الماضيه
حركه المسافرين السعوديين همم والمشجعين
ايضا باتجاه الدوحه
[موسيقى]
نعم نايف نتواجد الان في احدى الصلاه
المخصصه لنقل مشجعي كاس العالم الى قطر
هذه الصاله كما تشاهدون نقلت منذ الصباح
او غادرت منها منذ الصباح اكثر من 40
طائره تقل المشجعين لكاس العالم اماكن
مخصصه ثلاثه في دخول المسافرين المشجعين
والمتوجهين الى المونديال في قطر ايضا
اجهزه ذاتيه للخدمه واكثر من همم او 38
كونتر يتواجد عليه الموظفين بالاضافه الى
العديد من المتطوعين ربما الان همم
الرحلات معظمها غادرت من الرياض الى
الدوحه ولكن في هذه اللحظات نشاهد همم
الجاهزيه التي لا تزال مستمر في هذا
المكان واجهزه الخدمه الذاتيه كما تشاهدون
في حال الازدحام ربما يستفيد المسافرين من
هذه الاجهزه التي توفر خدمه همم بطاقه
صعود همم الطائره واستخراجها دون الحاجه
الى مراجعه الموظفين بالاضافه هذا الى همم
استخراج بطاقه صعود الطائره عبر التطبيقات
جاهزيه عاليه هنا ورصدنا ايضا نايف تفاعل
المسافرين والتفاؤل لديهم في هذه المباراه
الحاسمه والتي تعتبر همم ربما مباراه قدم
خلال المباريات الماضيه قدمه المنتخب
السعودي اداء رائع وايضا همم مدرب المنتخب
ايضا كشف بان همم المنتخب السعودي اليوم
سيقدم اداء مختلف وستكون هذه ان شاء الله
او هذه المباراه حاسمه في حال الفوز على
المكسيك نعم او في حال فوز بولندا على
الارجنتين تدخل في حسابات ايضا اخرى
حسابات التاهل على كل حال انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر نواف عزيز مراسل العربيه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض اشكر شبكه مراسلي العربيه
ايضا من مسقط
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي ومن الدوحه
مفيد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي وكذلك
منفذ العربيه من الدوحه عليك وزاري شكرا
جزيلا لكم
تصلون قصير الرابع
الضمان اتعبوا
لا تلعبوا
حرب في قلب نور قلوب
[موسيقى]
كم
ربكم
[موسيقى]
اول
الربي
ع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حياكم الله من جديد ومتابعه للحدث الاهم
هذا اليوم وهي مباراه المنتخب السعودي
امام نظيره المكسيكي والمتابعه اخبار
المونديال ايضا كذلك ننتقل الى الزميله
الرياضي
[موسيقى]
تحيه رياضيه اهلا بكم الى مجاز رياضيه
شكرا لك نايف تتوجه الانظار اليوم الى
استاد الوسيله الذي سيحتضى لمواجهه
السعوديه والمكسيك الحاسمه لحسابات التاهل
الى دوله من النهائي المنتخب السعودي يحتل
حاليا المركز الثالث بثلاث نقاط بينما
تملك المكسيك نقطه واحده تغيرت بها
المجموعه الثالثه
[تصفيق]
المنتخب السعودي يصل الدوحه محملا بامال
كبرى
مهمه صعبه جدا بداها امام الارجنتين التي
تدخل كاس العالم كابرز المرشحين لللقب فوز
تاريخي السعودي بهدفين لهدف والاحتفالات
تلف البلاد والعالم العربي
بعد لقاء باربعه ايام اثنان ممن لعبوا
مباراه الارجنتين يغيبون عن مواجهه بولندا
الاصابه تنهي مشوار القائد الفرج والمدافع
الشهراني في المونديال الخساره بهدفين
تصدم السعوديه مدربهم في المؤتمر يعلنونها
لم ننتهي بعد
حتى يتاهل الاخضر من هذه المجموعه سيلاقي
المكسيك ان انتصر سيعبر بغض النظر عن
نتيجه الارجنتين امام بولندا اما انت عدل
فانه سينتظر فوز بولندا في اي نتيجه او
الخساره امام التانجو بفارق اربعه اهداف
غيابات السعوديه امام المكسيك لم تقتصر
على الفرج والشهراني انضم اليهم محمد
البريكي المصاب وعبد الاله الملكي الموقف
بسبب الانذارات
جماهير السعوديه صنعت الحدث في الدوحه
لفتت الانتباه اليها بتفاعلها الكبير
وسهمت في زياده شعبيه المنتخب السعودي وهو
ما دعى المدرب رونالدو للرهاني عليها في
لقاء المكسيك حين طلبها بالحضور ودعم
الاخضر
[تصفيق]
افكار جديده
حتى لو لم تسجل المكسيك خلال كاس العالم
هذا فهي فريق قوي للغايه مع مهاجمين جيدين
للغايه لذلك نحن على درايه بكل شيء الان
اعتقد ان الامر سيصل مساء الغد الى
الثواني الاخيره لان التشويق سيكون في
الملعبين لذا على الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
مشاكل قلبيه ان يعتنوا بانفسهم غدا
في مباراه ثانيه يبحثوا فيها الطرفان عن
تاكيد احاقياتهما وحجز مقعد في دور 16
نلتقي منتخب الارجنتين بنظره البولندي ضمن
مباريات المجموعه الثالثه المنتخب
الارجنتيني يحتاج الى الفوز لضمايه تاهله
بالشكل المباشر او سيكفيه التعادل بشرط
عدم فوزي منتخب السعوديه وسيكون هدف ميسي
ورفاقه والانتصار بكل تاكيد لاثبات
جدارتهم بترشح للقبياس العالم بالمقابل
سيحتاج منتخب البولندي الى التعادل كا اقل
احتمال للوصول الى الدور المقبل
على استاد المدينه التعليميه تشبه منتخب
تونس بامله في التاهل الى الدور المقبل
عندما يواجه حمل لقب المنتخب الفرنسي يملك
نصور قرطاج نقطه واحده فيما ضمن المنتخب
الفرنسي تاهله الى الدوري المقبل
[تصفيق]
في الرابعه عشر من الشهر الحالي وصل
المنتخب التونسي الى العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه حاملا معه امل الملايين من عشاقه
من داخل وخارج البلاد لتجاوز دور
المجموعات للمره الاولى في تاريخه
[موسيقى]
تونس افتتحت مباريات المجموعه الرابعه
باداء قوي وتعادل سلبي امام المنتخب
الدنماركيه اسعد الجماهير التونسيه بعد
المباراه
[تصفيق]
واستراليا لكن النتيجه فاجات مخيبه
ومخالفه لتوقعاته التونسيين بخسارهن
رهنت سوري قرطاج في تخطي دوري المجموعات
قبل مواجهه بطل النسخه الماضيه المنتخب
الفرنسي
بصراحه هم نقطه
خساره استراليا جعلت تونس تتغييل المجموعه
الرابعه بنقطه في الرصيد وتضعها امام
حسابات صعبه لبلوغ الهدف المنشود هي الان
بحاجه للفوز على رفاق مبابي مع تعادل
استراليا والدنماركيه او فوزي المنتخب
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما زال عنا انشاص المساج نحب نعديهم
العبيدي وما يعرفوه اللي ما تم حتى شيء
مستحيل في كره القدم
كل الثقه وكل التحفيز مش الحقه نتيجه
ايجابيه ان شاء الله تكونوا موافقين اهم
شيء المعركه الاخيره خضوها بحول الله بشرف
مباشره
انطلاق مباراه تونس ومنتخب الفرنسي حمل
اللقب كيف رايت جماهير التونسيه وحتى
الجماهير العربيه التي تشجع منتخب تونس
اهلا لليان طبعا نحن بالقرب من في منطقه
قريبه من ملعب المدينه التعليميه همم
الوضع تونس مختلف نوعا ما عن وضع السعوديه
اليوم تونس لا تملك فرصه التاهل همم
بنفسها هي ستعتمد على نتائج الاخوه لذلك
هناك يعني توتر نوعا ما بين الجماهير
التونسيه ولكن يعني كنا قبل قليل في
الطريق باتجاه الملعب نشاهد عدد كبير من
الجماهير التونسيه وايضا عدد كبير من
الجماهير العربيه التي تتجه همم نحو
الملعب لدعم ومؤازره تونس هنا في قطر
العربي همم لا يقف خلف فقط ابناء وطنه
ولكن جميع الجماهير العربيه دائما تكون
دائما لجميع المنتخبات العربيه خصوصا ان
فيه دائما يطرح همم تذاكر او يعيد طرح
تذاكر حتى قبل المباراه بساعات لذلك هناك
فرص كبيره لتواجد الجماهير من جنسيات
مختلفه
جماهير كلها ايضا تنتظر مباراه المنتخب
السعودي مساءا يعني هناك تقريبا حوالي خمس
ساعات ولكن منذ امس كنا ايضا بمباشر من
الدوحه وكانت الجماهير تتحمس همم تتجمع
منذ الامس لتجيء على المنتخب الان كيف هو
الوضع همم هناك من عندك ما هو البرنامج
برنامج الجماهير قصه التذاكر ايضا اخبرنا
ما لديك نعيش من هناك
همم
الجمهور السعودي بدا بالتوافق من من امس
عبر الطائرات وايضا عبر ومنفذ سلوى
بالحافلات هناك تسهيلات كبيره للجماهير
السعوديه تقوم بها وزاره الرياضه جميع
الجهات الحكوميه السعوديه بالتعاون مع همم
لاجل المنظمه في همم قطر همم سيكون هناك
امس بالامس شاهدنا التجمع في همم تجاوب
الوسيل وتحفيز وتواجد جماهيري الكبير
للجمهور السعودي اليوم سيكون هناك همم
مسيره تبدا الساعه السادسه مساء نكون
متواجدين باذن الله هناك ستبدا المسيره
الساعه السادسه مساءا على الاقدام لمده
نصف ساعه حتى الوصول الى المنطقه الغريبه
همم من الملعب سيستشهد الاف الجماهير
السعوديه في ما يخص التذاكر هناك يعني طلب
كبير على همم التذاكر همم بالامس همم طاح
مجلس الجمهور السعودي ثلاثه الاف تذكره تم
بيعها
همم بشكل همم مباشر يعني في خمس دقائق
بيعه اكثر من 3000 تذكره فيفا قام بطوح
تذاكر مساء امس وبيعت بالكامل وقبل ساعتين
تقريبا فيفا ايضا طرح تذاكر فيفا يقوم
بالتاكد من من صاحب التذكره في حال عدم
حضوره الى قطر او اصدار همم بطاقه همم هيا
هو يقوم باعاده طرحها مره اخرى حتى يضمن
امتلاء الملاعب نعلم ان الوسيل همم 88,000
متفرج همم الجماهير السعوديه ستكون لها
الغالبيه همم العظمى وهي تفوق همم
الجماهير المكسيكيه بشكل كبير ايضا هناك
تيفو هناك استعدادات همم يرتدي الجمهور
السعودي القميص الابيض حتى يكون مثل
المنتخب السعودي الذي سيرتدي يوم القميص
الابيض داخل الارضيه الملعب طبعا سنكون
معك نايف همم بهذه المساله التي تكلمت
عنها في الساعه المقبله باذن الله شكرا
لكم
جماهير كلها جمهور لا المنتخب السعودي
جمال العربيه بشكل عام تدعم همم السعوديه
وتونس شكرا لك نايف
في مجموعه تونس وفرنسا يسعد المنتخب
الاسترالي للتاهل الى ثمن النهائي لاول
مره منذ نسخه 2016
عندما يلاقي المنتخب الدانماركي يحتل
الكونغو الاسترالي المركز الثاني بثلاث
نقاط بينما تحتل الدنمارك لمركز الثالث
بين نقطه متقدما على السكرتاج بفريق
الاهداف
[موسيقى]
وحسم المنتخب الانجليزي امس بطاقه الدور
16 بعد فوزه على وينز بثلاثه اهداف من دون
مقابل شوط المباراه الاول انتهى من دون
اهداف في مطلع الشوط الثاني نجح ماركوس
راشفورد بتسجيل الهدف الاول لمنتخب بلاده
من ركله حره وبعدها بدقيقه اضافه في الفرن
الهدف الثاني لانجلترا ومنتصف الشوط
الثاني اضاف راشفورد هدف الثالث والثاني
له
اما المنتخب الامريكي فحصنت تاهل كفاني
مجموعه بفوزها منتخب الايراني بهدف من دون
مقابل ضمن المجموعه الثانيه اذا الهدف
سجله كريستيان بوليسيتش قبل نهايه الشوط
الاول في مباراه نالت الكثير من الانتباه
حول العالم لاسباب غير رياضيه ترفع امريكا
التي ضربت موعدا معه هولندا في الدوري
المقبل ترفع رصيدها الى خمس نقاط خلف
انجلترا بينما تجمد الرصيد
ايران عندها ثلاث نقاط لي تودي على
البطوله
[تصفيق]
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
الى نايف تفضل نايف
[موسيقى]
شكرا ليليان شكرا لكم انتم لمتابعه هذه
التغطيه الخاصه في نشره الرابعه والتي
خصصناها بالكامل للحديث عن المنتخب
السعودي الذي يواجه المنتخب المكسيكي هذه
الليله لحسم بطاقه التاهل في مجموعه
المنتخب السعودي شكرا لكم
المتابعه ليله سعيده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا عارف مجموعتنا في كاس العالم
حتى الاتحاد
في البطوله المجموعه صعبه
ما هو متوقع فوزه او تعادل اللي نبغى منكم
تلعبون لعبكم المريح اللي يؤدي وان شاء
الله القادم افضل انا ما ابغى اي حد يكون
تحت ضغط
نفسي يمكن ياثر حتى على ادائكم الطبيعي
[موسيقى]